there are hundreds of goat breeds
available throughout the world but not
all these breeds are good for commercial
meat production business here we are
describing about top ten meat goat
breeds breeds the Virata is another meat
goat breed from Spain the breed is very
strong and durable and they can survive
in almost all climates a mature goat can
reach around or up to 70 kilograms body
weight by the way this breed is also
considered as one of the best meat goat
breeds breeds goats originally developed
from Spain but today it is available
throughout the world and raised as a
good meat goat breed these animals
require less care and they can thrive in
almost all climates climates the saroja
goat is actually from India and it is a
great breed for meat production these
animals are very Hardy and can survive
in almost all climates saroja goats are
mostly found in India and some other
South Asian countries they require less
care and they reproduce relatively
easily easily
rangeland is another very popular meat
goat breed from Australia this breed is
tall wide and has short hair rangeland
goats are very Hardy and they can
reproduce and live happily in dry areas
the breed require less care and also do
well in hot weather rangelands are
sometimes crossed with the boar goat for
producing good quality kids the kids
eugen goat is not only good for meat
production but also very good and used
for milk production and it can be called
as a dual purpose animal mature males
can reach up to 175 pounds live body
weight they are also sometimes crossed
with the boar goats for creating larger
sized meat goats goats the fainting aka
the myotonic goats are also good for
meat production they are actually known
for their unusual reaction when under
distress freezing for a couple of second
and fainting and this reaction actually
developed from a genetic disorder
fainting is a smaller sized meat goat
breed waiting around 175 pounds pounds
the Coco goat is a relatively new breed
of meat goat which was created recently
as the 1980s in New Zealand the breed
was actually created for meat production
by breeding feral goats with Saanen tah
and Berg and Anglo nubian goats pico
goats are very Hardy and they generally
can survive in most conditions they
require less care had great mothering
skills produce lean meat and also good
for milk production duction
[Music]
kalahari aka the red Kalahari goat is
similar in size and appearance to the
board goat
except the coloration it is a very
beautiful breed that was originated from
South Africa the breed is very Hardy and
they are able to breed and withstand hot
temperatures and dry weather condition
meat of the red Kalahari is more tender
than other breeds breeds boar goats are
large animals with a male can reach up
to 300 pounds they are one of the most
popular meat goat breeds for their large
size boar goats are very Hardy and
resistant to diseases and they also grow
very fast they also have great
reproduction quality boar goats actually
originated from South Africa in the
early 1900's hundreds black Bengal goat
is considered as the best meat goat
breed in terms of meat quality and taste
according to IAEA as the name suggests
the breed is actually from Bangladesh
but is also found in West Bengal Bihar
and Orissa of India meat of black Bengal
goat is of excellent quality and fetch
high prices both in local and
international markets size of this goat
is relatively smaller and its really
very easy to care for them